the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our broadcast of
the 2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco and I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster Tata of abrahamian and let's
go ahead and take a look at the
standings for groups for group a
and Darius weird Christopher you and
Yasser quesada and we have two players
illinishnik and Daniel Darda who are
chasing them by half a point so this is
a very closely contested group and in
group b we actually have one Soul Leader
gergelican tour with two and a half
points with Felix blowberger and Akshay
Chandra chasing him by half a point so
this last round yesterday was actually a
very bloody round and we are left with
one leader with two and a half out of
three
let's go ahead and look at the
tournament format so they are playing
game in 90 with a 30 second increments
for the first 40 moves then they will
get an additional 30 minutes for the
rest of the game after move 40 with a 30
second uh increment throughout the
entire game
and the schedule for the tournament is
they will be playing at 1 pm Central
Standard Time every single day with no
rest days we will come to you two hours
after the start of sorry three hours of
this after the start of each round
um live with coverage of the games
is there a game that you're looking
forward to seeing today looking at this
pairings for today uh definitely I'm
looking forward to any game Christopher
you is playing it seems like he plays uh
just psychotic chess every every game
and it's it's a pleasure to watch and
play and I did get to interview him
yesterday and we talked about both his
uh yesterday's games and his round two
that's very exciting Sicilian so it was
fascinating to talk to him about that
game and hopefully we have another
fascinating game by Krista for you but
our key matchup of today is going to be
between Sam sebian and Darius words so
let's jump into this and let's take a
look at what is happening on the board
so we have done we have some Savion with
the white pieces so looking at this
position what is your first reaction
um well I think it's clear that white
controls more the center than black
right now because white has more Central
pawns and this openf file might prove to
be dangerous for black to deal with in
the future that said
um black probably has the better Pawn
structure so I I don't know maybe I'd
slightly prefer to play white but not by
a whole lot
so the last move was Knight F3 so we can
expect to see Rook F3 we have a locked
position there's been move 21 about to
be in there have been no Pawn exchanges
I'm actually wondering if GTX F3 is an
option here with the idea of going F4
this might be interesting too changing
the pawn structure getting even more
Central pawns even yeah this uh there's
a lot of central pawns here so the
position is very locked but we do have a
lot of exchanges of the minor pieces
actually let's see how we got here
so we have this fornite variation of the
English with E4 so this move has been
trendy I we saw this at the American Cup
he Carly played it against Wesley in
this position so Bishop B4 was played
yeah actually I I would like to point
out like a funny line instead of Bishop
before black has the option of flame
Bishop C5 and um and this is what I was
hoping for when I was playing this
variation with white I only played it
once and then Knight takes E5 is the
move for white with the point being that
if you play Knight takes E5 white will
play the move Pawn to D4 now this is
still playable for black but black must
play them a bishop to B4 but normally
the reaction instead of it should be
four would be something like Bishop D6
to support the Knight on E5 and that
would be like pretty good if White had
to take on E5 but here white is the very
strong move C5 oh C5 and uh I believe
black is in big trouble here
um you're just gonna get destroyed in
the center with uh with the black pieces
so you need to move this Knight and then
you end up with something very
unfortunate yeah yeah this is a nice
trick
but instead they after D4 they go but
should be four and it's just like a
normal position
the bishop actually doesn't get trapped
here Bishop lands on B6 Knight A4 so the
idea is to get this bishop unclaim to
Bishop advantage
so Rook B1 so not in a hurry to take
this bishop Bishop three take Stakes
and Bishops actually challenge each
other 98 so there has been a game
between Abdul Saturn and Kiri so in that
game I was just checking it white took
on D4 and allowed the spawn structure
change and here white played Queen
Detroit allowing 96 so now if y takes
then the Knight can take back so instead
the Knight Returns which would be a
pretty uh severe positional concession I
think white would would be mistaken to
play this this way yeah we'll get very
classical good night versus a bad Bishop
position because the future of this
bishop is not clear although we did talk
a lot about the potential of Bishops and
that kind of players really favor this
long potential of having a bishop
something like if this bishop could
slime back and play a four on up on the
position
but there is no reason for why to allow
this instead Knight C3 was played
stream
so and then 92 so well right now
actually taking on D4 and it takes D4
this bishop won't have anywhere to go
but
black trades and white decides to take
with the pawn of course it's also
possible to take this way but uh F takes
you three changes the pawn structure and
uh I think there's gonna be a great big
question about this H5 move if black is
going to regret playing H5 I think that
C6 would be more of a
normal reaction to control this D5
square but instead black chose to play
H5 yeah that's actually why probably why
I chose to play F takes E3 so that the
Knight on E6 cannot access the D4 and F4
squares this change of structure uh
oftentimes favors white if you can
eliminate Black's future night jumps
to G5
side
g6s plate and we landed here so actually
no Knight after is on the board so white
hasn't played yet so white is still
blinking so there's of course three ways
to recapture with the pawn queen and the
Rook so I I think it's a matter I don't
know if there's much difference between
capturing with the queen and the Rook so
I think it's a matter if white wants to
play GTX F3 and change the structure and
maybe go King H2 Rook G1 you'll get fun
and F4 F5 you can correct me if I'm
wrong but I think that Queen takes F3 is
just a worse version of a rook takes
because
um with Rook takes you're threatening to
double your X on the f file whereas with
Queen takes it takes an extra turn to
bring the other Rook to F1 so I think
he's choosing between G takes F3 and
Rook takes F3 and not Queen takes F3
here even if objectively maybe Queen
takes is better than G takes
to make because this will change the
course of the game
and any anytime we change upon structure
that actually like pound structures do
decide um where the pieces goes so this
is a big consideration for white
and I wonder how black is going to react
to this so where is plugs play in this
position probably associated with A5
playing on the side of the board so
let's say B5 and at some point
especially with this Pawn structure
black should try to play
T5 and I think D5 yeah I totally I
totally agree I think if black can
achieve D5 in a good way then he
shouldn't be too much worse
just opening up the center
okay so uh a big decision for white I
think because
this can really determine the flow of
the game and while Sam is thinking about
his decision let's take a look at the
pairings in group b and see what we have
there
and what stands out to you in this group
so obviously our key matchup uh girgili
Cantor vs Akshay Chandra is going to be
pretty interesting because Gregory
Cantor has clear first and octron is not
too far behind with plus one
um so if he wins this game he will have
a role reversal he will be at least tied
for first although this will be quite an
Ask playing with the black pieces
against the tournament leader
and let's take a look at what we have on
the board
so looking at this position
looks like some kind of a queen's Indian
Queen's Gambit declined what do you
think about this position
um I prefer to play this with with white
I like White's activity in these sorts
of positions I understand black has like
this long-term potential with the bishop
pair and that's probably why the
computer thinks it's a pretty equal but
I've played both sides of these
positions before and I found just plain
playing with white it's so likely that
maybe not at this level but at my level
I make so many mistakes but early that I
would prefer playing with the initiative
than the long-term potential of the
Bishops is there some kind of
three Queen H5 yeah I think Queen H5 is
a really an interesting candidate move
right now although apparently apparently
not V5 is hanging so if B5 and Lego Rook
G3 I guess maybe you can just take on D4
oh now E5 is hanging unfortunately and
we're not on time
otherwise this might have been pretty
strong
so Black's last move was Bishop D7
attacking this pawn and now white has a
decision to make if they want to trade
this really powerful Central Knight for
this bishop or somehow defend the pawn
although I don't see a very comfortable
way of defending this Pawn because the
Rook cannot go to B3 Bishop C4 looks
awkward so does Queen V1 it doesn't feel
like the queen wants to be on V1 so I
would think taking on D7 is probably the
most likely move for white I don't
really see a good candidate move yeah
maybe we can take on D7 and then uh okay
B5 is still hanging yeah so take on D7
and D5 I thought was interesting but I'm
question of heart I don't think I can
take back with the queen
uh why not
oh no I don't have Rookery three ideas
this looked a bit scary to me because I
didn't like allowing this maybe D5 here
I was thinking about this but oh now I
don't have this
even still we probably have some
compensation if we just play like I was
thinking D6 maybe I just want to keep
pushing but
yeah
and black is also getting active and if
both players are active and one side's
up material well over their compensation
is is uh
not going to be as strong as if your
opponent were passive right
let's see how we got we got here and
what was the opening so white starts
with D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 D5 and
Bishop B4 so we have the rokosin one of
the sharper lines
so all of this is still Theory
Castle Rook C1 yeah this is also
Mainline takes C5
I remember there was if this was the
line uh where Gary hats that came from
with answer he won very quickly I don't
think it was this particular line
is a big fan of the Rocco's and he likes
to play these positions a lot 94. a
quite annoying move
attacking the queen pushing the bishop
back and now Pawn takes and white does
give himself an isolated Pawn but if you
look at the position white is done with
their development
and The Rook is on C1 and black is
lacking in development so there is a lot
of compensation of course for this
isolated pun as we talked about it
yesterday when you do have this weakness
of isolated Pond piece of activity is
very important and again white has
exchanged their light Square Bishop
their darts where Bishop and is left
with their light Square Bishop so the
good Bishop they're left with and D5 can
come at some point but I think that's
also double H because it does open the
position and like it does have the
bishop pair
I will say it's uh it just shows how
strong Bishops are in comparison to
Knights because the computer uh assesses
this position as uh equally supposed by
by the bar but like all of White's
pieces are like super active and black
hasn't developed their entire Queen side
of computers like nah the bishop is
worth that much
yeah the long-term potential is just
that strong
so before it is played Bishop goes to B6
Rook C3
also defense against any kind of Bishop
D formos now black starts to develop
an A5
this is an unusual idea that white is
played like Rook C3 to D3
um I actually haven't seen this idea in
these positions too often
it's interesting this would be five
Bishop slides back rookie one so the
idea is associated with playing D5
so 95 is played which looks like a
natural move and now Bishop D7 and we
are in this position where we just
looked at
um was there a moment where white should
get in D5 yeah I think instead of 95
maybe D5 was possible immediately
so it takes
um Bishop takes maybe Knight C3 also
yeah I want to jump with this Knight
somewhere nice okay where does this
queen go I was
okay I was afraid of the so your
Tactical point is after Queen A3 Knight
D5 you have Queen a uh so Queen A2
Knight C7 and you're probably doing
really well
my two seven I might even have Knight E7
but I think this should also be quite
good
so your Rook goes where
that's a good question yeah okay so
you're not gonna play it okay seven so I
I think something like this is
um abandoned in the back rank seems like
suicide right at this moment in time but
if you play here now I'm pinning you so
at rookie I might
some background issues but I'm not sure
how you're going to entangle
and 95 97 winning a piece is also quite
strong
so this looks a bit scary I don't think
you can just abandon your entire
position and go upon hunting yeah fun
grabbing too ambitious at this point in
time so what can we do maybe if Bishop
B6 then Knight takes
the danger I think for white isn't isn't
so much that he's losing anything but
maybe we just are trading all the pieces
and it becomes equal like if we go Queen
C5 or D6 yeah
and if Knight C7 here then Queen C7 and
just all the pieces have been traded and
why is black worse in fact A3 is
probably weak yeah here I might also
prefer block a little bit so so maybe I
need to just leave everything as it is
you don't want to take wait is this
hanging yeah my knee-jerk reaction was
that I liked white but the more I think
about it the more I'm I'm thinking that
maybe Black's doing pretty well
because you just don't have anything
immediate and Black's position is quite
solid actually the pawn structure is a
black just needs a few moves to develop
so which is why I wanted to do something
a bit more concrete here
maybe it's a rookie one native f8
um
by the fact what can we do I need I need
my Rook but I can't I don't even need
cannot get my Rook here actually what I
need is a dark squared Bishop all of a
sudden that's what I need I think I
think the reason why Black's position is
so passive is because he uh he took that
guy yeah with the dark Square Bishop I
think white might be just winning
so Bishop I'm inside I expect to see
take I don't think Queen B1 will be
played so in Queen V1 sometimes you know
there's just funny ideas that black even
puts the bishop here so here might be
difficult but sometimes the bishop
enters it's like a French idea the
bishop enters from this side but I don't
think it's necessary to put the bishop
on E8 so this this Pawn is quite weak
right so there's I've seen this kind of
moves too
but Bishop D7 and uh okay so we'll see
probably takes
which way are we going to take with that
Queen D7 right Bishop D7 is the current
position yeah yeah okay cool
no Queen H5 sorry should be seven I got
lost in my arrows and now maybe Queen H5
3 that's kind of annoying but maybe
something like Bishop B1 Rook H3
yeah then maybe Knight F6 could even be
like strong
actually maybe if black isn't careful we
can play
like is Knight F6 an idea even without
bringing more pieces in into the game
like Knight F6 takes Queen H6 and Rook
H3 followed by Bishop B1 okay so if I
pass a move you want to give me a knight
and then and then Queen H6 like maybe
this is more interesting than it looks
because after Rook H3 Bishop B1 comes
like right away and we're immediately
getting into Black's position
yeah and the fact that the rookies here
might be annoying because you may not be
able to escape like maybe I'm even
threatening like Rook E6 or Bishop E6
something to that effect yeah this
position actually is starting to look a
bit scary so maybe something like this
is so he took Knight D7 and also maybe
not Queen D7 but the Rook design looks a
bit awkward because then you run into
Knight to five and Knight D7 is also
possible maybe this is um have been
followed by Knight F6 is also might be
logical can I go D5 here
yeah Knight D7 seems pretty solid
maybe the night jumps white would love
to play D5 at the right moment because I
really do want to take advantage of this
um
rook and queen being on the same file
for sure
but I think we can move with other games
and
um so let's see what other interesting
games we have here
so this position that I had these guys
seem like they're going towards towards
a draw I think so we have uh Bishop
versus knight Rook end game and the
position looks very balanced but yeah so
there was a repetition okay this game is
actually over
this is a three-fold okay so this one is
a draw
do you want to take a look at some of
the games in the uh in the a group
that be Christopher's game I always want
to see what he's up to I think uh might
be a bit disappointed as there are no
Pawn chains for a piece
Chris
there's always balance in the
Christopher you game so here I think
it's just up to pawn so there's not much
of an imbalance
so it's just two extra Pawns but okay so
this is hanging sure let's see what's
going on I'm sure he's not complaining
so it just looks very good for white I
just white just has a very healthy Pond
this fund is very close to queening it
just looks like that Catalan line with
an early Knight take C6 gone like
horribly wrong I don't know if let's see
that's what happened but
oh it's it's not Bishop B4 check what I
was thinking this came from was instead
of Bishop B4 it was like Bishop E7 then
Bishop G2 castles castles DC4 uh 95
Knight C6 and then Bishop C6 I like the
structure is sort of similar
these positions later where black goes
like E5 but it came from just a
different line
so it came from the special before check
shook those back
uh this looks like
94.
that Pro looks kind of a bit committal
94 indicates I guess you want to play
some kind of Stonewall
it's F5 I don't know
oh it sucks
can I take just a pawn sacrifice
so Knight F6 Queen goes to D3
what is the idea we should be seven I
guess so um you know during the US
Championship
um Christopher you I saw Christopher you
playing in the Casual play area of the
St Louis chess club and he was
practicing against this engine
um that only it was a like a lobotomized
version of stockfish
that only cared about material so it's
like very good at calculation so it sees
tactics but it doesn't care about
positional Chess at all so like in the
opening thinks all moves are equally
good because they don't hang material
right
um and uh uh it was just beating him
like pretty consistently I think the
engine was yeah the engine so it would
have nonsense positions then like just
went up material
um I wonder if this factored into his
decision making just winning a pawn for
nothing here but he didn't yeah
so black compensation is connected with
uh having a bishop and this weakness of
light square but all the cattle and
positions that I've seen wherever white
does give up this light Square Bishop
there's actually at some point they play
F3 and there is no attack and no
Checkmate so most of the time this is
quite okay
so Knight C3 and goes through the rim
so what happened in this game it's
basically he took a pawn and stayed up a
pawn
and F3
I mean sometimes that's that's how it is
like the engine says you you win a pawn
and it's compensation but you need to
prove it and
here if you're just up a pawn okay like
I guess black can immediately get
something back with precise calculation
but E5 is timed and
so maybe
will repeat because in this position
actually can I
no I don't think I want to take with the
queen so if I take how do you yeah E2
King because I don't think he won a lot
is because now all of a sudden your king
is very lonely here and
your queen on the other side of the
board this looks a little too dangerous
missing the lay Square Bishop isn't too
good in that type of position so
if you're in no good way can I go oh
Bishop C4 is yeah that's what I was
gonna point out yeah E3 Bishop C4 might
be awkward to deal with
so if I take
first of all are you trapping my queen
yeah what do you
where does the queen go after Rook B8 I
think oh okay okay but then
no then I'll go back to C3
so can you trap my queen here because
the evaluation dropped which tells me
there must be something here
um
take
maybe I go Rook C6 and after Queen A5 I
play Queen H3
like I just play for the attack instead
of trying to trap your queen
um
yeah in that case I think rugby the
strong but wait can I can I do this
where does this queen go
oh I think this traps the queen okay
there are no more Queen moves okay
so he was okay with this trade but not
with this so I think maybe he's actually
applying for initiative not a block that
is so Bishop B3 really nice move
np5
okay so takes takes Queen D5 offering a
queen trade Queen E5 is a really nice
move centralizing the queen and
attacking this Pawn or maybe this is
what um
Daniel missed
94 but now we don't we're not in a hurry
to take because of the pain so Knight
goes to E4
and now it takes so in this position
Queen went to D7 but if we trade
oh F5 also hangs after Knight D4 this is
quite sad also the bishop doesn't have
I think if you go here um I don't take I
have probably Knight F2 Knight D6 and
this guy is hanging we're up a pond this
is just very bad
instead he won Queen D7 Knight C5 but at
this point so he's not afraid of giving
up this Pawn because Knight D4 I think
looks very strong
do I have Queen D6 perhaps
yeah Queen D6 looks good hopefully I
don't get mated okay so if you take this
must be just came over
yeah
and if the queen goes uh Quinn doesn't
actually have many squares to go to
only move
but it's the scary for me
Knight F4 might eject the queen from H3
oh yeah this can't you don't have time
to take yeah this looks quite nice
although maybe we're allowing too much
counter play
so but if not Knight D4 maybe simply
just Queens no Queen slice Back the
Night jump so what can we do
can we start with C6 is that is that
interesting because if you play Queen
takes I now I play Knight D4 so I don't
have a way to defend my Bishop I guess I
have oh no thanks to
and if I
I H3
Knight D4 in any case
and if here you
Queen F5 oh this is yeah with the
intention if you take take and take on
F3 I'm hoping the Knight D6 wins a clean
Exchange
because if you take on E3 then C8 is
hanging and there's nothing protecting
it yeah this looks and there's nothing
to really worry about here because after
check we can just run this way and we're
gonna Bishop alone I'm not going to
Checkmate this King yeah the blacks down
an awful lot of material
so in this position we're looking at
Bishop E2 but instead of rookie it was
played it's a Tempo move Queen D6 is
really nice
of course this kind of a trade it's the
um this is just silver
so instead the queen went to B5 and
we're nearing the position we saw so
Knight D4 is the position with sir Queen
B2 Queen B6 it really wants to trade
queens and I think here he's forcing a
crane trade right right this coin is
trapped
so takes takes Knight D5
was Queen is six the best way if I could
link B1
you go here
um can I do something terrible to you
out of five you know but I look at this
position and I'm also thinking something
like this and maybe
your king will be in trouble but okay E2
is hanging so I think even if Queen B6
wasn't like the best objective move he's
just concerned that if Queen stay on the
board something bad could happen to the
king and if Queens are off the board
well it's minimum two result position if
not just flat out winning for white
so takes takes Knight D5 so the clock
situation 25 minutes against 10 of 7
moves to make not that many moves uh so
now actually if I move my bishop and my
oh my Pawn is hanging what am I doing so
how do I save my pawn it might be
more interest like Bishop Bishop F2
Knight B6 maybe Knight C6 is an idea
just because B6 is hanging okay I I
is defending C8 should I go somewhere
yeah actually because if I go here you
think
um no but can you go to D7 and then uh
just
right in the bishop
oh wait no
yeah yeah Bishop B7 simultaneous yeah
wait no I'm the one who's in trouble
because I'm
so in this position what
what um yeah I wonder what is it okay
what if I take so how do you take ah
yeah and then Rook A5 is a fork so it
attacks D5 and the A6 Bishop so it
doesn't matter that E3 is hanging
well I actually didn't realize it's a
fork I just thought I should maybe start
with Roxy okay so then I have to take
with Bishop C8
and yeah but now we can uh but now okay
so no this is still hanging but
uh
let's see if I go let's say Bishop F2
which I think is very logical and just
play this four versus three right but it
feels like we should have had more than
this but I mean why it is up up a clean
Pond and can press I suppose
the opposite color Bishops a lot of
pieces have come
out this is the fight so that means that
in this position so you know like we
have this evaluation bar which of course
influences our thinking
but during the game maybe this just
looks scarier so maybe he just thought
this is very annoying it too is hanging
doesn't want to lose this Pawn
and wants to trade
um wants to trade Queens but uh what
else can we do if not so this is hanging
it is hanging
Rook C2 is not a move so rugby one is
the only other move that comes to mind
it's a Tempo move
so the queen moves and now
it just seems like so many things are
hanging so maybe I need to give up the
spawn let's say slide back
you take and everything is defended
right F3 is defended Bishop defense
tonight
um
maybe rugby seven
I'm not sure which is the chips yeah I
it looks I'm honestly surprised at the
eval bar is so high like when I don't
see anything concrete and if there's
nothing concrete then why would black be
worse
yeah
maybe I mean fun is very strong if your
side is very strong the pieces are just
good if you take on E2 with the with
with the Knight then obviously rookie 2
is like a problem but
um no which actually rookie time a bit
afraid I was thinking you had to play
Rook YouTube because Queen E2
is a blunder
oh you have Queen C7 yeah background
issues that makes sense
so instead I have to take with the queen
but I don't like giving up my knight
because
that's true but we we do have this
bishop versus knight in the pawn on c5s
is good probably yeah this bishop is
quite strong so so
but white cannot get made it here really
so maybe this is an option but I I
completely understand this queen B6 move
because the screen is just so annoying
here but I wonder what he missed so we
have some more moves
so let me promote this wait so he is
playing this for V3
so where are we so he took he went he
took he won Bishop D2 so he gave this up
so he took and here so he is playing
this so um
which way will this bishop go to C3 or
C3 I'm assuming C3 yeah Rook E3 maybe
Rook A8 you have to consider after Rook
E3 oh yeah
okay yeah but maybe Knight B6
B8 I think the bishop versus knight is
isn't actually good for black anymore
with the pawns being all on the same
side
yeah usually when we have pawns on both
sides of the board the bishop is
significantly stronger but when we have
pawns on one side of the port
at the Knight is doing much better so we
have this position on the board
Bishop can go to C3 I don't know do I
want my Bishop on F4 do I have one on
this diagonal like here it looks nice I
think both both should be good to be
honest
and white is going to just be pressing
this forever this is a very going to be
very annoying and game to defend yeah
Christopher really um he he has all all
the skills he he he's incredibly good at
this tactical chess and now he is uh
showing how to press uh a slight
Advantage with the white pieces
yeah
at Sam's game so let's see oh a lot of
changes in this position
so he took with the
wait what happened so he took with the
Rook the Knight went back Knight C3
Knight G5
so Rook D1 preparing D4 Queen G5
offering a trade of Queens
white accepts and deform
so there has been a change in the pawn
structure but this makes me a bit
nervous because okay if we ever trade
and this E43 pawns are so ugly so white
just wants to keep this
Pawn structure static doesn't really
want um those exchanges to happen like
this kind of exchange would be nice but
we don't want to take only five and uh
maybe at some point this could be
possible I think one wants to play D5 C5
in a good way like if you can break
through in the center then then our the
E4 E3 pawns start to make more sense
obviously you never want to play C takes
D5 if white plays D5 then we would
probably be much worse
so if I go A5 B5 is this possible and
maybe something like Rook C8 with the
idea of taking yeah Rexy it looks like a
good move
C8 let's say
let's say maybe the other way even oh
just so that Knight A4 doesn't come
and with the idea I just want to take
and claim that you have some problems
um I think this position can also be
dangerous for white because it feels a
bit like an over extension maybe because
it looks really nice to have so many
pawns this is what Christopher had right
here yesterday he had like A5 B5 C5 D5
but sometimes the spawns can be
overextended
so if I go something like this and open
the C file then it's going to be really
loose I think black would be in a lot
more trouble if there were more pieces
on the board like black has done a good
job trading a lot of pieces because
white has more space and uh black so to
speak has a nice lack of pieces for his
lack of space
and another game that we have is Yasser
quesada he is one of the co-leaders but
okay the position that we have is
completely equal yeah I don't foresee
anybody winning this no where would move
41 so I this point is actually
indefensible
so I expect this to end in a draw would
it not surprise me if the players just
agreed to a draw because there is no 40
move no draw rule but we're on move 41
okay so I think this is a draw for 95
Rook B7
and just trade everyone
so there will be the first result of the
game after round
so two of the leaders will draw each
other which means that no uh the Ilia
and yeser will not take a um a soul lead
going into round number four or sorry
round number five
and uh this game between hakubov and
Benjamin bug
so what is going on so one two three I
have to count pounds one two three four
five six so white is up a pawn and
looks like quite a nice position for
white
this king is weak this king is made
safer
I think actually white has a really nice
Edge in this position I
would um the last one was Knight F5
where did this Knight come from oh he
just grabbed the pawn
neither five so maybe there is
dynamically somehow
a way for uh black to win the pawn back
okay so if I take this uh looks quite
unfortunate because this King just in a
box cannot move this cannot be good for
example if the Rook goes to E5 I think
this is already game over yeah this is
just Unstoppable mate
so this is cannot be allowed so taking
this also cannot be good because
while it's just up a pawn and this is
hanging so let's find another move oh
yeah there was a game yesterday I think
it was um it was somebody against
yesterday quesada Perez was it Luke
Higgins yes or quesada Perez but there
was this Pawn on H6 though or Uno was on
F6 and it was really annoying it was the
same sort of situation these major piece
end games if you get a Pawn on the sixth
rank with with white there's always like
midi Nets to worry about
so the queen has to move somewhere where
should we move the queen not there I
don't know how it landed there
um so we have to go somewhere to defend
the Rook somewhere
where should we go maybe here here here
not that many moves so we have one two
three moves can we go to f8 if we can go
to f8 and take on F5 then take on H6
okay so the queen will go well why can't
I go there yeah so we go here here take
on H6 King G2
still I think maybe a bit Pleasant for
white but
it's a roku's T1 to F6 start pushing
this Pawn yeah still some pressure for
white
yeah my next move rookie E6 is coming
right and I'm threatening to win a pawn
yeah even though it's equal material
white is definitely the one on the
better side of this because um in major
piece end games you would rather have
the safer King in the past pawns yeah I
think white has a slight edge here and
final
look at
a Mishra versus gladorum so in this
position uh what is going on here what
do you think
so we have an end game Rooks and Bishops
some material is one two three four five
six material is equal what was the last
move Bishop exchange is offered to get
rid of this bishop again we're seeing
isolated Pawn but
there's also the weakness of e3 and once
the Bishops are off the board ah no this
is a repetition
that's why we have to look back okay
this is also a draw yeah because once
these bishops come off then this E3 Pawn
will compensate for this D5 Pawn both H3
and E3 will be very weak so there'll be
two weaknesses for once uh for Roblox
one weakness and
this defined weakness is much easier to
defend so you know weakness is only a
weakness if you can exploit it as you as
you said yesterday
um yeah so not a particularly bloody
round from the a group it's very likely
that Christopher will will take a soul
lead if I had to guess after after this
round at least he has the highest
probability of doing so how did the
slide plan here
so we'll land it here so Bishop one to
B4 we're saying so H6 just making sure
there's no back rank made through K7
Knight goes to E3 and I'm to see okay so
93 so I think he'll be thrilled with a
repetition but Christopher is probably
not that nice so how does uh White make
progress so probably put a Pawn on G4
against the spawn structure it's very
convenient that our Knight is on D4 so
there's no Knight C2 yeah Knight on D4
such a beautiful piece hopefully I'm not
blundering anything
well I think even if I allow this this
doesn't work out tactically per K8 at
the end is very nice then we pick up a
piece
so we're reach move 40 although I have
to say Christopher plays very quickly
and yesterday when I was talking to him
I asked him about uh that run to game
against Mishra because he was an hour
ahead on the clock and I said like why
do you think you should have just
thought about why didn't you spend more
time you said yeah at some point I
probably should have so he plays quite
quickly and he's
going to get an additional 30 minutes so
he will have 50 minutes to his opponents
37 minutes um I expect this game to go
on for a long time unless Christopher
plays very quickly but I think he will
take his time here trying to convert
yeah it's on the one hand when you play
very quickly you're more likely to make
mistakes on the other hand it can be
very scary to play against somebody
playing like that fast and you you know
they just pass the turn to you
constantly and you're down on time and
then it's a tough position you have no
time and they have time yeah it's a lot
of pressure when you constantly have to
make decisions and your opponent's
playing fast double edged definitely but
I have to say you know when you're in a
bad position like really bad position
and you're in time travel there's also
psychological it can be difficult for
your opponent because they get like very
emotional and they don't know if they're
playing on your time or in the position
and if you have some resources you're a
tricky player you can Swindle them
yeah it wasn't I think it was carp off
he would put himself in time pressure on
purpose when he was like losing Detroit
that's a trick that I've heard about
from jams before you just you know you
have to be a resourceful in chess right
it's a practical game at the end of the
day and that's a way to
give yourself some chance
so we're done with group a we looked at
every game let's go to Group B so let's
see if we have any updates oh wow we
have a lot of updates in this game
so rookie one was played Knight f8 95
so this trade happened now D5
it takes D5 oh I would be so scared to
take this Pawn Yeah we Analyze This
variation right it was Ed and then we
had Knight C3 or was that was that in a
different spot it was you know different
but why not Knight C3 here
if Queen ate three Queen A3 cannot be
possible no actually it is possible I
don't know yeah we just win D7 yeah
and then you cannot really defend your
piece because I have both Knight E7
and I also have Rook C3 right yeah I
pick up those little moves like crushing
and he took with the bishop but now
95 came with a tampon
and now the tables have turned because
now it is white who's coming under pins
yeah and you have to you probably just
have to give up the A3 Pawn which is why
like like if you move your Rook off the
um the third rank like you go to D2 then
I think Queen A3 is like legitimately
just possible for for black
yeah because there is no Bishop
[Music]
actually why did it drop
what's the problem Oh Bishop A5 is even
stronger oh wow yeah that that just wins
the game
ah now we see this bishop coming into
place so that's the thing right because
there's fun in some way is controlling
this bishop and one this once this pawn
moves this bishop just becomes a monster
so oops I went back too far D5 takes
takes yeah Knight C3 would have been a
very strong
because because a bit uncomfortable uh
maybe he was afraid of 95 but even still
no D5 yeah and maybe maybe now there is
a pin but the queen has to find a square
because here
are here again you take
I run into this tactic already
okay but I can't just move my rope right
because this is so defended like Rook G3
is maybe hard to deal with practically
any of the square is maybe attack
because yeah G3 you don't want to put it
on the same line as the bishop but I was
thinking that maybe it doesn't matter
because the knight's blocking and we
might have some tactical Resources with
Knight F6 later
if Knight G6 and Rook G6 I don't
maybe I can just
go like this Knight here actually this
looks strong because now maybe I can
take at some point
and I don't have to worry about any kind
of pins on my queen yeah but in any case
the Knight on D5 is very strong so I'm
surprised he he didn't go for this like
even The Rook C3 Quincy the queen C3
variation you're probably not worse with
white and with what he did I wonder
he definitely missed something I'm just
not sure what he missed I
don't actually
that's because this point might just
fall yeah so I'm nervous about that okay
but Bishop D5 can I see so he took it he
took a minute to take so 95 is played
and okay we saw maybe so here this just
runs into Bishop B6 forcing your bike
and Bishop A5
and now the Rook went to G3
he played King h8
just sidestepping any kind of Adventures
and I I think White's claim is that this
pin is just going to be very annoying
and now Knight C3 but now this bishop A5
is
but yeah and there's too many pins going
on there's this pin there's this pin we
have to Bishop A5 there's a third pin
yeah there's another pin
so at least he got out of two pins right
from Bishop under Rook so King h8 very
nice move so F4 is not possible because
there's a check
but can I attack this
okay three or just F6
I wanted to win a piece right away
actually is it possible if I take take
and go here can you defend oh yeah
Bishop F3
um how else can I attack this
ah I have a oh I have such a nice tactic
here
so you cannot take with the queen
because mate so you have to take with
the pawn yeah and you collect both Rooks
it really stumble into this tactic
it's like a Checkers tactic you just
take all the pieces at once this is like
puzzle Rush right yeah yeah Rook D5 it's
very nice
yeah this was a this would be quite
unfortunate so how did we get here we
went Bishop A5
and we played what so the leader of the
tournament is in quite a bit of trouble
right now it's very likely to lose the
game which is good news for the other
participants because they have a chance
to acquire the lead
you have to say that idea which you know
I totally saw when I went Mission but
after Bishop A5 what that's why I do
because it's actually quite a bit of
pressure for white to find a move
um
yeah Rook C8 is coming queen is like
there are improving moves for for black
in this position even if
you try to save yourself the problem for
white is all these pins you cannot
really defend or reinforce the pieces
with black I can at some point play F6 I
can't play
Queen F6 and move my queen out of the
attack still defend the Knight but for
white there is no way to move the pieces
in a way that they still work together
for example something like Queen F3 I
would love to play but I can't
if I was hanging and as we saw rookie
three yeah everything is it's not
working very awkward for white and this
is going to be a very likely role
reversal aksha Chandra will be uh tied
for first at after this round bare
minimum yeah so he will actually
overtake the leader right he was half an
hour half a point of a proper Point
behind the litter so
he will LeapFrog him so Bishop A5 is on
the board and white is thinking we see
the players in the playing cold and very
uncomfortable position with three
minutes on the clock akshat has four
minutes I have played akshat several
times and having little time is
Not Unusual for him he does get into a
lot of time trouble that's do I so all
our teams get decided in time travel but
this is very uncomfortable for white
because white actually has to find a
move that doesn't immediately lose the
game which
uh I so the immediate threat in this
position is Rook C8 looks very strong
right
um
it's Bishop C3 ah Bishop C3 is already a
threat so if we pass the move which is
not possible well okay we did with
rookie three right
so the idea is to take
take on D5 and play that Knight F3 move
which we found yeah so and if a H3 or
something to defend against it then I
think Rook a C8 is going to be really
tough for
um
well ah here it doesn't work because you
can play G or queen of theory Rook F3
yeah yeah this actually defends and now
white is quite happy here but uh yeah
instead of Bishop C3 we can just play
Rook C8 and I don't I don't think white
has a very good defense against that
because now what are we threatening so
we're just threatening just to remove
the defender and pick up a piece and
this just looks
this just looks over yeah like if you go
Queen A1 or something you're like I'm
very clever I have defended all my
pieces then Rook C3 will come and Rook
C3 Bishop C3 Rook D5 and about to make a
move let's see what he's going to play
or well oh you wanted to take yeah so
take Stakes but now do I have a four a
Knight F3 she takes off three although I
missed I missed that four huh
but okay I mean if you stumble into this
position you can do this then you still
can claim a huge Advantage here yeah
although I wasn't winning a piece the
way that I wanted to which is
unfortunate but actually that's that
happens to me in a lot of games when I
play low rated players I play like some
tactic it doesn't like win but then like
their position gets bad and then I like
got lucky and went anyway somehow
so Rick A4 was played I'm going to
promote this so what is the idea after
because the thing is when I take on C3
I'm also defending my knight so you know
you don't have something like Queenie 2
rookie 3 I just simply take and I
defended my knight
so I expect aksha to play Rook ac8 and
this will turn the tables it's actually
a very quick game where I move 26 and
things are going very badly for white
and he has two minutes just a little
over two minutes actually it has three
minutes but I think rookie seat is a
very natural move and maybe he's
calculating something more concrete
but here are lines
um wait so if we take take
do our lines work out here
can we there's some background issues
right
so Rook d8 yeah
and the queen would love to go here but
it cannot go here so it's funny if you
play Rook takes E5 you're like yes I
have both files controlled but I can uh
play Rook takes D5 and whichever piece
you take I back rank meet you with the
other piece yeah this is fun information
and this H6 move quite useful because
otherwise there'd be some background
issues
would say
yeah so maybe he's already calculating
okay so he's calculating this so I think
he took on C3 no
wait where did my red box go
um oh yeah yeah yeah I have too many
variations here I'm a little lost
no so I took on C3 and now we're we're
expecting this Rook D5 Rook d8 variation
I guess is there anything else can I
play Queen D6 even
that Queen D6 you will defend
now I'm expecting him to play Rook D5
because I don't think he will take this
um yeah he has I see on the screen he's
played Eric D5 yeah Rook D5 played very
concrete so I'm pleasant when your
position is bad and you have no time
unless you have tricks
yeah no this and the bar tells us that
this is the correct way of playing so in
this position uh he has to give up the
queen I don't even know how to give up
the queen because if I give it up this
way I think I'm gonna lose this is just
a full P Stone yeah queen and a knight
for turoks it's not even equal in Queens
and knights generally work pretty well
together so especially if it's an
exercise especially when it's an extra
night so this will be our first decisive
result of the round I expect akshat to
convert this okay he is done quite a bit
okay both are down quite a bit of time
so Luca sorry gergel is going under two
minutes there's still a lot of moves to
make to reach move 40 but with an extra
piece I don't expect him
to have too much trouble and I think
your girl is realizing that things are
going very poorly for him he doesn't
have any kind of tricks like this
because simply Queen D6 is enough and
then the Knight will move there is no
yeah akshard is looking pretty confident
right now he's set back in his chair
it's all on Google it's a proof
something but I I expect the game to be
over pretty soon to be honest so I I saw
tomorrow moves being played what was
played so it takes
yeah the queen D5 Rook d8 were the last
two moves played never played oh yeah
okay I also see it here I I couldn't
tell if it's hard enough I saw it I saw
it on the screen yeah yeah so he
immediately plays rook d8 and now one
minute on the clock and I think we can
expect
[Music]
um
a result in this game very quickly and I
can see yeah we vertical is suffering a
bit yeah we expect a result here any
minute now
a really nice result for rockshad
winning with the black pieces so yeah I
don't want to jinx it but yeah I expect
this to be over so we have this will be
the second result right we had
um
I thought we had a repetition in this
in this section oh no we don't have a
wrap this in in the section I'm mistaken
we had a reputation in group a
there was a game that ended in group a
so do we have any more moves in this
game we do not but he is 30 in 30
seconds so he has to make a move
otherwise he's going to flag
yeah
he hasn't moved yet so
I think it's just kind of coming in
terms of the fact that this game is
going to be over very soon
yes sometimes when you have very little
time left you uh like if you have a lot
of times and you'll resign but you know
you have too little time to resign I've
I've felt like that before my position
is really bad and I have no time but I'm
like I have no time I can't resign I
might as well keep playing just playing
adrenaline so he took on the eight
immediately takes back
and he made some other move maybe he
took 25. no Rook C3 okay oh yeah this is
a this is actually a nice trick so if
you play Queen D1 here then you can
actually not win the game because rookie
won and the Knight on E5 and the Queen
on D1 are hanging but after the move
like
um oh and also F6 yeah doesn't doesn't
work because of uh F4 but if you don't
have F6 then you're losing your knight
so F6 has to be played so if F4
uh there has to be oh we missed this
actually yeah this is a this is a nice a
nice way to keep the game going actually
oh wait no you can play you can play
Queen no no I was thinking Queen D2
takes an F5 but you just go rookie two
there
[Music]
oh maybe yeah queen queen C1 check
oh yeah Quincy one check you win a piece
and then Queen C5 and F4 yeah that's
that's that's probably it
is there an easier way of doing this
wait I want to form C3 so idea was okay
so we have to play F6
only move right
the Knight cannot move yeah unfortunate
uh Queen D1 check with satisfied so F so
he did find a resource that's really
nice something we completely missed
so F6 has to be played and now F4 yeah
and then is Queen D2 the only move I
would be very surprised if that's the
case
um due to the online
oh actually yeah maybe Queen yeah Queen
B6 here and if you take then F5 is the
same idea but it's stronger because you
don't even have like a rook block so The
Rook on e4 cannot remain on the um on
the E file and once it moves we just
take on E3 very nice yeah this is a
really nice move
let's see if app shot is going to find
it so this is such an unpleasant
thinking just when you think you're
winning and then your opponent finds a
resource even if it's not
um
a resource that's saving the game but
something you missed it's just so
unpleasant
but he has he has less than uh 90
seconds so it's a minute and a half so
let's see what he's going to play but F6
has to be played there's nothing else at
the very least yeah because Queen D1
it's just rookie one yeah if actually
doesn't play F6 then
then he probably won't win the game and
I mean
yeah probably he will find F6
yeah I don't because I don't think I
don't think he will go for something
like like this
claim
I don't think he will do this
also positionally if you play F6 and
your opponent has to play F4 that's
probably a worse version for white then
um than this position right you would
rather have the pawn F2 even even if you
don't see like Queen attacking a rook
then F5
oh maybe he missed it maybe he won't
find us because he just now
he needs to find well he has to play F6
and then immediately white will respond
with F4 only move and then
and then he has to find this queen B6 or
this queen D1 Queen D2 idea
but yeah shout out to
um Cantor for making things tricky even
even here like myself I might have just
resigned and then I would have uh lost
with no hope but
uh he's always he's in there with a
fight right now
in the Knight F3 so he missed he missed
this F6 idea
[Music]
commentators curse yeah I just the
second I said he's going to win this I
immediately regretted it
but yeah he is going to be so upset when
he looks at the game
after the around
but now can I take
yeah no it's not not clear at all how
black is going to win the game no no the
bar is just this is so unfortunate he is
going to be so upset because he didn't
even have to go for this bishop C3 movie
you could have just played Rook C8 but
he went for this very concrete line
thinking he's completely winning and
missing this rupee three
and
um this this part of Chess where this
emotional part of Chess is so difficult
to deal with when
things change he's thinking about it
like I can tell it's like what went
wrong it's like when there is a huge
change in the positions mentally
emotionally it's so hard to deal with it
and it doesn't matter which way it goes
I think sometimes if it goes you have a
bad position sometimes you get a good
position it also can be difficult to
deal with because it's such a huge
change and then your opponent offers you
a drone because you're in a bad position
for so long sometimes you just take it
because you're just happy to be over it
but like any kind of um you know this
cold shower feeling when you feel like
you miss something it's just so
unpleasant yeah it's going to be so
upset after the game it is it is
potentially the worst feeling in the
world going from being like winning to
draw in and then drawing to losing like
uh I can't think of a more unpleasant
experience in the world well well let me
tell you
there's like a lot like a lot of ways to
suffer any chance chess is um yeah just
chills can hurt you in a lot of ways for
sure
but I think white is going to survive
this he just needs to make it no but now
they both have men and a half and they
have to make it move to move 40. yeah
this is very unfortunate
Let's uh well let's move on to other
games as we're in time travel so we must
have time travel in many games
so they are actually not this game this
game is over so this was a three-fold so
we have a draw
Kirk versus Felix and this game also
looks
so black is up upon not the most
impressive pawns and
also closer to Troy I think and anything
else not because there's just simply not
a lot of material left on the board
and in this game the engine Bond Terrace
tells me that black is doing really well
so what is going on here so one two
three four five so black is up a pawn
and opponent literally looks quite
impressive
so what is um can I I cannot win a pawn
yeah take take D2 oh it's not possible
because E7 is hating so Bishop G5 Maybe
5 I think you're happy because you come
back so we want to threaten
um
we want to threaten too no we just play
Bishop C5 yeah Bishop C5 and if you go
Bishop E3 then D2
if you play Knight E3 then also D2 yeah
dito just wins everything here actually
then you win both pieces yeah okay so
taking the pawn is not possible I've
just gotten a word that there's a result
so mihilevski has defeated a duden in
the um
in the B group oh that's a lot of Queens
yeah wait ah this is so nice
let's checkmate actually we didn't get a
chance to look at this game but we will
take a look at michalevsky if he comes
for an interview
so the game works uh we're looking at so
we saw this one so we're expecting at
least two decisive result we're
expecting three and akshat
um yeah but unfortunately that looks
like we'll beat draw and in this game
black is done Western but certain well
rather Balaji dagupati versus Don
basuring but Surin
black is doing really well this D5 Pawn
cannot be taken and this Pawn looks like
it's going to be queening
so what else white play so maybe
oh no the actual game is over I'm
assuming in a draw oh so disappointing
that was that was a pretty pretty big
Miss from aksha but yeah it's never easy
in time pressure
yeah he doesn't look happy no he's going
to check and he's going to be extremely
upset
which is such an unpleasant feeling but
it's just um
part of Chess yep and this game we had a
decisive result and uh
is this game what is going on it says
that white is out of time so what
happened in this game actually
curious to know
and what was this so this was a Karo
Khan
it's quite a sharp line
takes the five so again we have this
French structure we had yesterday
avoiding a queen trade but against the
structure sometimes this is a bit scary
so the Knight goes to G3 and Knight
wants to land on H5
black has to play F5 because a lying F5
is too scary
so now we have a very french-like
structure but quite a nice Fringe for
black because no light squared Bishops
and this bishop is a terrible piece
especially that white has put upon on F4
it's a white immediately plays F5 but
runs into tactically five because taking
is impossible
it's a very nice move Rook C4 is also a
really nice move
because after takes takes you still
cannot take Bishop C5
so Rook C1 but simply picks up a pawn
so 94 and we are
landed so um I wonder if there's some
issue with the digital because
I'm not sure block would resign here for
example if I go here I mean if white
would resign here because if I go King
F1
what do you do can you take even maybe
here
yeah
I think I'm just losing a piece
yeah it looks like this ponds are just I
mean this
what whoops yeah in my mind I took Sean
C1 so takes takes but okay two
connectors Bishop G5 is coming uh it's a
very simple win
there has to be
so this game we will find out what
happened in this game and
do you want to take a look at
Christopher's game real quick always
always back on Christopher actually
let me update it so we have a lot of
moves so we left up here
so Bishop went to D2 so this is a trade
that black would be very happy with but
even here with the presence of Rooks
whites can still press but of course
I shouldn't allow a trait when they're
opposites a color Bishop so Knight one
two C6 Bishop B6 E4 now white is making
some progress the problem with this
Knight
um just getting kicked around
and this is the problem when you don't
have an outpost for a night it's just
getting harassed on the board I have
gotten word that uh domper CERN has
actually defeated dagger party so
um in Group B that game was yeah black
oh sorry white resigned yeah that makes
sense maybe he just thought he just
can't find the movement he didn't want
to play this terrible position anymore
yeah okay so that makes sense
is going higher and higher
um yeah again the problem with knights
in this open positions when there is a
bishop they just get kicked around
because if I come back and take this
like this Knight is just not finding a
square
and white will play G4 H4 and G5 either
H5 or G5 or just G5
and create a pass plan at some point and
I quite like to move G4 in these 4v3
structures even if there were no pieces
left on the board I think that Black's
defensive task becomes much harder if
white can achieve the move G4
black would really like to already have
the move H5 on the board in this sort of
position that's why I was going back to
fact yeah it's just
G4 extent expansion because g4i as you
mentioned is very strong in these
positions and actually quite annoying
for black to do it because the problem
for black also black needs to find moves
it's actually not so simple to find a
move in this position for example if you
go to Rook C8 I don't have a check okay
but I'll go probably Knight D4
and at some point I might just take this
bishop and if you
yeah for example if you do something
like this and not cover the square this
is already on 93 yeah but still like for
um
the seventh rank becomes so much weaker
once once the structure is changed like
this yeah and at some point white will
play Knight D4 and try to take this
bishop
take the bishop but threatened to take
the bishop and then claim that
this Knight doesn't have a square also
possible that maybe I can
play with something like or let's defend
this G4 Pawn like let's say if I can
play H4 defend this Pawn then F4 F5
after moving this bishop and claim that
these pieces don't have any squares to
go to and just kick them around so this
is actually quite a difficult defensive
task ahead of flag and I do feel like
white has made a lot of progress wait he
actually played H4 but now this allows
us to play H5 and I think this is quite
helpful
yeah that's an interesting decision
I just got news that uh Mishra and
gladora have made a draw
which makes sense because I think
I thought this was a rep
so this game also ended in a trial so we
have one two draws and oh four against
three so something went wrong for Savion
let's see where we left off we left off
here
so F5 T4 was played this is the final
position we signed an A5 and he took no
he didn't take
he went to H4 black took
takes takes
um of course this is just to unpleasant
also loses upon uh but yeah this
expansion uh can be very scary because
now The Rook comes in and things start
to get loose yeah so C5 this was your
move right you wanted to do something
like this yeah but I think you're
concretely
uh plug uh yeah
and Rook T8 so D5 so this was again your
idea
and okay so I think something is going
to hang here right we'll give five
ah now I cannot move this Knight because
this Pawn hangs
so now it becomes difficult to defend
everyone so
Rook B2 so he defends the opponent
instead of exchanging and Knight F6
so take yeah now we see some problems in
the position this is the downside of
having the structure is the later and
later you get in the game the worse it
becomes
so we have a force versus four versus
three
um so what kind of a four versus three
is this
um
structure is actually nice for white
because it's very difficult to create a
past one because if you play something
like this this is not the kind of two
versus one
for example I'm gonna try to make moves
without hanging things
you go G5
yeah so you create two versus one this
is not a two versus one I'm very afraid
of also some activity for my king
because
um if if we take this Pawns
the spawns of the board this is a very
easy draw
yeah I I don't know so practically
though instead of exchanging pawns
um I was thinking maybe I can move my
Rook away and it would be dangerous if I
can get Keen F5 E4 in like I guess you
have to meet kina5 with E4 all the time
because
well I can maybe put my king on it for
myself yeah sorry so instead of Rook D3
like Rook A5 or something to that effect
and maybe you have to go Rook B6 here
because k95 E4 is actually uh White is
winning the game it's pretty funny so
you have to go back and
but yeah if you don't play
if you don't play Rook B6 and you allow
me to play Kane F5 and I get to the G4
Square I think you might end up in
trouble but I wonder if now I can maybe
do this but now here you can actually
try to play a five
so in this position when you go here or
so here yeah I have to play Rook V6 okay
white still has of course black can just
play this for a long time
but uh I think this I think this Pawn
being here is actually quite like this
Pawn structure but especially with the
pawn h4h5 this is quite variable for
white yeah for sure these four v3s with
H4 H5 exchanges usually beneficial for
the defender
and
the last game that we had okay so this
game actually went down as we were
expecting it
so in this position with a knight F5
Queen went here so it was predicted all
of this
Queen went to G6 offering a trade uh
this is uh actually interesting offer of
trade because D3 also hangs here
um can you take oh he did take this is
so scary because you're back rank Rook
C1 and he goes back this is very
cold-blooded but
so Queen E4 King G1 Queen F5
and um
what's the material the material is now
equal still some problems with this King
but maybe if I can
um
you know if I can get in like H5 H4
maybe I can be happy so where should I
go with this route me I want to defend
my
it's a formal I wanted to Define my
seven rank so
so okay I don't get made it and I wanted
to maybe try
it for the thing is you also cannot get
too active here right queen of three
might eventually be like something like
even this
I don't know because the thing is if you
you control a lot of squares
and then King G4 yeah you could lose the
game king of seven King G4 that's it
that would be unfortunate yeah yeah
that's very funny so Queen A5 is played
so we're Richmond 40 so now the players
get additional 30 minutes I would expect
black to spend some time here uh maybe
A4 was actually a bigger threat after
this so maybe this is something to deal
with
and not give up this Pawn I'm not
totally sure how you deal with that you
can't play Rook B7 because Queen A8
would pick up a Rooks and Rook D5 also
seems scared to hear this man actually
get made it yeah there's there's a uh
but we might run into the same issue
right like if we keep checking Black's
Kingdom black black king and a bun G4
and
like how bad can it actually be oh
because H7 is again defended okay H5 and
then kg4 yeah
Okay so
so okay something to consider because A4
seems to be some kind of a threat in the
position I don't want to put my Rook
here it's very passive here
so maybe
35 immediately so not a long way for it
all possibly it feels so scary too baby
you came that way but if you put your ah
Roxy it is not a check even so Roxy it
was only checked because my Rook was on
this oven but yeah if I start cutting
you off on the seven Rank and
this looks a bit scary but maybe Queen
is seven
yeah I mean there's so many ways to and
I'm finding all of them to lose this
game
and now this hangs and there's
background mate okay this should not go
well for us
too many squares for a white there yeah
actually
it's here
well practically I think quite easier to
play with white because this King
immediately is weaker than this King and
with the Queens on the board and their
Heavies on the board it's quite scary
Yeah the more moves you make the more
I'm convinced I'd lose with either color
yeah well I think for white to lose they
have to try but for black they can just
kind of maybe make an inaccuracy
for example if I play A4 and then if I
move my queen with a temple somewhere
and then go A5
then all of a sudden have a fast Pawn
so it can be a bit tricky there
so this game I wanted to check okay so
we're just maybe shuffling a bit
and this game was over and Christopher
you game stop pressing but black gave
him the option oh so black is traded
pawns headed black managed to do that
so we saw this right oh H4 he went F5
this is another reason to but maybe he
was was he afraid of this move but this
movie looks so dangerous for me because
if I go age four
this one may not be able to live for too
long but instead he played at
um F5 so trade and
uh the safety of this king without this
Pawn actually worries me like if my
Bishop would could somehow go to E5 this
would be really devastating actually I'm
really concerned about this King even
with so few pieces left on the board and
then now maybe I can play Rook C7 and
ask where this Knight is going and ask
where his Bishop is going yet the Knight
leaves on the C4 Square then the bishop
on F4 will find
um nice squares like anywhere on the
lawn diagonal I think would be pretty
nice for white right now so where does
this bishop go let's say I go to G6
yeah brick C7 like you were pointing out
um
let's say here oh
yeah great fork okay so I have to go
here these pieces are moving on their
own like I touch a piece and then just
lands on a square maybe Knight B2 is
also possible
maybe there's also might be some safety
no this King will be very safe on H3 I
don't have to worry about this King
it may be Bishop yeah Bishop D6 G4
and then
maybe yeah I think you should play well
it's so double-edged to play H5 on the
one hand you stopped me from playing H5
because if you don't play H5 I'm gonna
play H5
on the other hand if F4 F5 comes as
you're pointing out um
you might just lose the game yeah
immediately resigns
okay so the position that we have
[Music]
to E6
so if I go roxy7
with my very
mysterious threat uh what do you do
so you cannot go here right it's the
same trick yeah so the Knight has to
start moving away so it has to go
this is the only square right your
knight cannot go here this is ridiculous
so you have to go here right and then
Bishop but now I have Bishop oh no I
don't know
now I will go here like this night the
safety of this Knight actually worries
me because your night can possibly get
not trapped at least like push to the
other side of the board and just never
come back this Knight is just not secure
if H5 here do you take it or do you play
G5 yeah
um what would you do
oh
what did I do maybe take it
it's a free Pawn of this you can claim I
have to pond
that's fair
yeah but maybe and if you don't actually
we have to calculate because G5 if I
have F4 F5 coming then this might just
be a win
yeah I mean so computers giving like
very or not not like huge numbers for
white but I think practically this is
going to be real really tough for for
black to defend yeah this is a very
a very tough uh position to play so what
did he play he played G4 so
and he has twice as much time on the
clock
and the problem with for black is they
also have to think about the margin of
error how much
how many opportunities do you have to
make inaccurate moves and get away with
it or does every move need to be precise
so for example this again right loses a
piece
I've lost this piece on the six ranks so
many found so many ways to lose the fees
like black has to make a move what does
black play in this position
because you cannot go back right and it
goes to F5 so this immediately it's bad
if the net goes to F5 and hits all the
pawns on the king side I can't imagine
Black's gonna be okay so my threat is to
play Rook C7
again yeah
and so what do you do I want to
process of elimination right like so I
cannot move to Bishop can I move the
bishop here this looks very sad maybe I
need to stay on this diagonal now we're
figuring it out because I cannot allow
Knight F5 Knight if I was just game over
so I'd have to stay on this day I don't
know and now finally after Rook C7 I can
play a move that's not Knight B2 okay
finally the Knight can go to V6 without
losing a piece
refund
Ed yeah
so but here I'll probably play King G3
to avoid any kind of forks
and again Buck has to find a move
what are you doing so maybe Knight V6
yeah Bishop D6 wanna play Bishop B5
can I play it I want to play G5 now I
don't want to trade pawns it also feels
like black is going to get made into
like if I go here here it like trade and
any
somehow it feels like you might even get
made it even though like trading funds
just makes no sense
yeah maybe night the reason why I was
thinking Bishop D6 was I thought that
your F4 F5 might be useful here as well
maybe I'm allowing Rook E3 or something
to that effect it might be some activity
oh and then G4 my tank
yeah it has to be timed slightly better
yeah okay yeah if we can play Bishop E5
let's put all our pieces on E5
it's a G4 black has to make a move and
this I think this is the the most
difficult part you know you have like
you have some kind of a setup right and
you have defensive setup but then you
have to make a move which means a piece
has to move from one of those defensive
squares and they're not that many
squares to go to because we're only
playing on this side of the board
there's nothing on the coin side so
Black's position is very tough It's
actually I really like watching this
kind of games because I think my
technique is not very strong so when I
see strong players
converting this kind of positions I
think they're so instructive just to see
how they do it because they don't do
anything to pre um at precise so
concrete they just kind of make moves
make improving moves and asking your
opponent every move uh like make a move
and you know you give them a chance to
make their position worse because they
also have to make decisions and just
sitting for a very long time is so
difficult
yeah for for sure and um you know maybe
you don't think of Christopher as like a
very technical player especially after
his last two rounds but I mean he's a
2600 Grand Master and I don't think
there's a 26 2600 Grandmaster out there
with like very bad Technique No
definitely not
so black to move uh has to find but
black has moved but I cannot
I'm gonna click on a different game and
come back to see black smoke rookie
seven ah this is a move we did not
consider so this trade black is thrilled
with this trade this Rook is so annoying
and in general whenever you have
opposite color Bishops Rooks give you
huge chances to win without Rooks we
know a lot of positions down the pond on
two pawns they were drawing but once we
add a pair of Rooks huge chances for the
panda for the sides that's pressing
so after rookie seven uh where is this
root going so I can check
yeah I actually think
um in any type of position where you
have well okay fantastic concrete game
so there are going to be exceptions to
this but when you're playing uh the
defensive side of a position you want
different kinds of pieces like if you
have a bishop you want your opponent to
have a knight if you have a knight you
want them to have a bishop so that you
can control like one color complex and
they control the other and the worst
case is with opposite Bishops because
one side just controls one color and
then you control one color and that's
how progress uh doesn't get made
on the other hand when you're attacking
opposite color Bishops are so useful
because if you attack on the same color
as your vision of your opponent's Bishop
is just useless you cannot do anything
it's so interesting how small things in
a position can completely change the
what's important
so what do we have here so rookie seven
I can check you of course you can no you
cannot go okay
so here you go King F7 but now this
worries me a bit because if I go here
what do you do in a bit we can still go
Rook D7 right the night but it's still
controlling E5 I think this look can I
go my idea was to do this and
rookie seven is actually a really nice
defensive move by black I mean
showing his defensive technique
Christopher showing his offensive
technique but Daniel showing that it's
not so easy to make progress with white
either
but I think I like this through k6
I also like this through k6 and maybe
King F7 can be met with Rook C6 so a lot
of um again very annoying for black to
play this position and to try to find
moves that
are not going to result in some kind of
a something terrible where everything
hangs so I keep hanging these pieces
so we will have an interview very
shortly but I will quickly take a look
at where we are so we have in this
position in pog's game he played rookie
8.
some Savion versus Taro this four versus
three not a lot of not many changes
this game has ended Christopher you
we've been looking at and we also see
this game has ended and in group b we
know we have several results already so
we know actually true a really
disappointing result Kirk was also draws
and
Victor michalevsky winning his second
game of the tournament and we do have
him in the studio so welcome back
congratulations we actually didn't get a
chance to look at your game so we can
look at it together so let's go
um to your game and please tell us where
is your preparation what were you
expecting uh I expected Bishop before a
check this line but I didn't expect A5
already because he mostly played Bishop
D6 before
so that's what I prepared but A5 I
couldn't remember any Theory here so
Bishop G2 I just knew some ideas but
nothing concrete
so
yeah Queen C2 yeah I assume it's all
Siri but
well I think the good thing is for your
moves are so natural right even if you
don't know Theory or pieces just have
their attention yeah it's a typical
catalog compensation for the phone
and B5 yeah but sometimes if you don't
really know you may end up on down and
so
around this okay so he so he hangs onto
the pond between is also very typical
all of this is very typical but then
I don't know if white I mean white has
compensation for sure but I don't know
if it's enough or anything
like for any advantage or
and before what do you think a lot about
allowing this past Pawn
it's also typical to allow before B
takes A4 is another possible idea I said
and then put a bishop on before yes so I
would have probably taken on S6 and then
yeah then probably just
okay so before was played yeah
yeah
it looks a little scary to allow Knight
C3 but anyway I cannot stop it so
yeah it's important that Bishop takes E2
tactics uh won't work
um
Knight B3 and I'm protecting everything
like
92 92 and this should be good
yeah I saw it for a long time before
playing E3 looks like a very complicated
position I consider it Bishop E4 idea to
Provo G6 because if he exchanges the
Knight I thought it will be good for me
just Queen takes
yeah
but he just plays G6 basically his idea
is to play F6 at some point yeah kick
this Knight away yeah and uh okay so you
just want to prove up G6 system yeah
after F6 I want to take Knight C6 so I
didn't know maybe to provoke G6 and then
after F6 still Knight existing
instead you play three you're in
reinforce your Center yeah and the
YouTube Pawn is not hanging in some
lines
so now I take take seven if Rock seeds
and I have Bishop D7
and The Rook takes C5 D takes C5 my
Bishop is protected but I wasn't sure
even this position he may have
compensation like Rook C5 dc5 Queen C5
Bishop E6 King h8
my lights were selling a little weak and
the Knight on sister is pretty strong so
ah you have but you have a you have a
tactic here I mean tactical yeah yeah
yeah then it's probably good okay so
instead he went Rook A7 stopping any
Bishop D7 Queen B3 so you did win your
Pawn back but at this yeah but this
position still looks fine I think Bishop
his idea is to just play five foot at
some point so I can't get and he
wants to play five so I thought I need
to exchange the strong Knight on C3
so he really wants to have something
else
yeah Rook C1 runs into 92 of course
thank you
serok C2
he digs takes
yeah F5
yeah somehow I believe black should be
fine here so how did you evaluate this
position
probably about equal but I'm not even
sure who is playing for a win in this
position
computer shows it's better for black
right yeah
it could be yeah
seven 65 okay so if you take this Pawn
you'll be quite happy
yeah then I go Queen B2 so yeah I wasn't
sure about this position so Rook C they
just I thought they can take on A5 oh
you want to click on A5 maybe if it's
possible I don't know like Rook C1
Bishop F1 I wasn't sure about this oh
this looks very scary for you
but I have this here at The Rook C5 Rook
C5 Queen before I feel like he should do
something he doesn't have time for E5 F4
stuff like so I have two more physical
yeah like Queen D6 and then yeah I don't
know if I can untangle somehow
[Music]
it should be okay for me but it's still
very concrete because he has Rook c326
these three ideas I cannot take the Rook
because of B2
so over here here Queen B6 but then I
thought maybe Rook 85
it's becoming some kind of a ponderance
but this looks very good for
good for probably I can even play 687
rouquet Shades that's my suit
very strong
so he played first queen B6 rookie five
and then rocks it I checked you first
but this check is is it helpful he went
to A1 just to stop my uh to stop my idea
five five okay yeah he just said that he
missed Roxy's 385 I kept this
intermediate move if he plays instead of
Rook C1 check I thought it's very strong
and then I if takes Queen takes C3 and
the queen E5 Queen before I map upon oh
very nice and a nice structure yes
that's very nice but uh oh sorry yes so
yeah D5 I think yeah should be played
and we should pay for Queen V2 tune you
take and yeah it should be good for me
so here probably it's already good for
white
so D is six
I assumed it should win and he was also
in the time trouble it's impossible to
stop this 26 no he can stop because if
Queen D5 Rook D1 ah
I left here yeah he just did yeah
so you want to clean up someone with
huge threats it's a group D1 anyways
yeah and now you're just check meeting
uh right he said that he he could play
Queen F6 in this position
I'm not sure how to press it here there
should be some way but so here here and
yeah this one is actually kind of
dangerous too right yeah but I should
have something maybe four no I don't
know maybe you can bring this bishop
what is computer suggesting here H5 P3
Bishop F1 oh it doesn't care about
kirika
[Music]
yeah this is very powerful yeah so the
problem still winning it
so he went Rook D2 but then I mean by
force Queen Aid Bishop F5 indeed
checkmate
um very nice game well congratulations
so now you're in the lead with uh three
point people no no I have two and a half
I lost yesterday oh yeah you lost
yesterday okay and who do you play
tomorrow I have no idea okay everyone
spoil it for you well thank you so much
for joining us congratulations on your
win thank you okay so let's continue
looking at the other games so let's go
back to group a the important game we
had of crystal for you so a few moves
have been made so Knight D4 has been
made Bishop E6
the pawn went to G4 rookie seven
Rook A6 so this is where we left out
king F7 and H5 so again the same
position the same problem as before that
black needs to find moves and uh another
very long battle ahead for um for black
to Define to defend this and in Samuel
savion's game versus Doris
not much has changed very few moves have
been made so this four versus three so
now this F7 Pawn is under attack which
means this king is not free to move
oh the king cannot go to F5 as Julian
was pointing out with the idea of E4
because the spawn is hanging and in B
group we have
we have one game going so this is the
only game we have going I believe and we
saw this position a long time ago and
here it's starting to look a bit
[Music]
um
a bit better for black I think black can
just pick up a pawn is there something
missing something
but maybe still a lot of compensation
for white associated with this um this
pawn something like
here and maybe pick up some funds and go
into some kind of a two versus one and
game possibly it just seems like these
pawns are falling and can point out some
funny lines again
so it seems very likely that in the B
group that Greg uh that gurgly Cantor
will remain in the lead because
um unfortunately aksha missed his chance
to overtake him and it also seems very
likely that in the a group there'll
everybody who's leading before will
still be still be leading now
um
let's take a look at the standings and
see where we are after the results of
today so we have two draws so far in
group a which puts Yasser quesada half a
point ahead of the pack but we do expect
at least a few people a few players to
join him and it's possible that
Christopher you will win his game and
will become the clear leader and in
group b it doesn't look like we had too
many changes as gergelicanto stays ahead
as we pointed out his opponent
um actually Chandra did not manage to
win that game which I'm sure he's going
to be very upset about and there is now
pack of players four players chasing him
by half a point
so yeah be sure to tune in tomorrow at 4
pm Central Standard Time where we'll be
covering all the games from groups A and
B have it going
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited